if the colors of the leaves weren't
telling us otherwise you'd be forgiven
for thinking it was spring the warm
sunshine is confusing the plants and the
head Gardener here at birmingham's
Botanical Gardens
forecast to be 20 degrees today which is
about nine degrees warmer than it should
be this plant here is uh Paris commonly
called Forest Flame or flame of the
forest they normally grow their leaves
in the springtime the older leaves have
been sort of almost burnt off by the
Heat and the drought of the summertime
but then here we've got these young
bright green leaves which have been
growing during the Autumn so the plant
thinks it's spring it does indeed
and look around and you see a tourist in
a t-shirt summer flowers in full bloom
and a cactus collection that's normally
safely indoors from the start of October
still thriving in the mild Autumn
weather obviously worries all of us
doesn't it really just think well how
will it be in decades to come and it's
not just in the UK but across much of
Europe in Spain and in France people
have been basking in the Autumn sunshine
in Germany too it's still warm enough
for this so why is it so mild at the
moment we have the jet stream that's
running very actively across the UK and
that's leading to a series of low
pressure centers we're getting our warm
air from western parts of Europe around
Portugal Spain where it is also
exceptionally warm for the time of year
and all that warm air is coming across
the UK leading to temperatures being so
far above average at the moment
but many will see this unseasonal Autumn
and the scorching summer that went
before it as tangible evidence that our
climate is changing and with world
leaders due to meet next month for the
cop 27 climate Summit the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak has been criticized for
choosing not to attend due to what
Downing Street have described as other
pressing commitments
but the pressing issue here is where the
rare habitats will be affected the
National Trust is warning its chalk
grasslands are under threat temperatures
are forecast to drop closer to average
next month but fragile ecosystems need
predictable Seasons to survive Becky
Johnson Sky News